joining me now Jeff Sessions former
attorney general and now candidate again
for the US Senate and Alabama senator
sessions what is your big takeaway from
today
well it's certainly to me I agree with
Ken Starr this is a very serious time
for America it does not appear to me
that they have the kind of evidence that
would justify going forward I called it
a show trial
what's a show trial when you've decided
the the person is guilty and then you
pretend to have a trial and fourth show
so this is the kind of thing that's I
think concerning up to a lot of people
the Constitution says impeachment is not
anything Congress says it is it says
it's for a conviction of treason bribery
high crimes and misdemeanors those are
restraining laws in our Constitution
that restrains Congress and they need to
be faithful to their responsibilities
and fundamentally I would just urge our
con Democratic members of Congress to
think deeply about the future of this
country the danger to this Republic that
would occur if we continue to prosecute
people basically because we don't like
them or we have a political disagreement
senator what more can members of the
Republican Party serving in Congress
today do for this president and for his
agenda that they're not doing perhaps
not trying to criticize but maybe a
little advice of what they can do better
or more to help this administration we
have to take the case to the people both
on all the issues he's advocating like
you know ending illegality at the border
standing up to China being more
restrained in the deployment of American
forces around the groats globe in
hostile places on this impeachment I
think they've got to speak out pretty
aggressively and say where's the beef
what is the charge does it meet the
constitutional standards and be open
about that I think we have a lot of
members that are so hopefully but that
message needs to be strongly put out
there
and Republicans need to be confident
that if if the evidence does not support
impeachment they are perfectly safe and
and it's the honorable thing to do the
only thing to do is oppose impeachment a
senator are you in the retrospect when
you look back and you know we all look
back on decisions we've made are you
glad you left the Senate to go work in
the Trump administration are you glad
that you made that decision Laura I
don't look back on those kind of matters
I made the decision I thought was right
at the time a lot of people think all we
did was deal with Russia but we had a
tremendous revitalization of federal
criminal prosecutions throughout the
country a revitalization of partnerships
with our state and local allies we stood
up for religious liberty and issued a
new policy we helped the president
appoint the best group of federal judges
ever been appointed we advanced his
agenda we reduce regulations so there
was so much that was done we started a
new group to intensify our efforts to
prosecute frauds and the i-team networks
and particularly China so a lot of good
things that occurred and I had 15 years
in the department I knew a lot about it
and I feel like we did a good job and
now I have an opportunity to seek the
Senate seat again and I'll be pleased to
ask the people valve now I'm going to
give me that opportunity and if you
could you know the president
occasionally watches his show is there
anything you'd like to say to him
tonight
he won't he didn't have a better
supporter in the United States Senate
then when I was there I was his first
supporter in the United States Senate
and if I go back to the United States
Senate he won't have a more aggressive a
determined supporter when I get back and
Senator what do you say to those
Republicans and there you know you know
who they are we don't have to name them
who say well this president is he's not
a real conservative he's not he's not
really doing the conservative thing he's
not bringing the movement along he's
spending too much time on these side
fights what do you say to them I tell
you this president has moved a
conservative agenda
in a host of areas he cut taxes isn't
that conservative he stands up for
America first throughout the world isn't
that good
defending American manufacturing
factoring gets cheating by China and
other countries isn't that conservative
and lawful he's trying to defend our
borders in a way that no affects the
rule of law in America so I just think
he's been conservative consistently to a
degree I think very few people expected
but most importantly he's been effective
and faithful in what he promised he told
the American people what he would do a
lot of people doubted he would do it but
he's done it better than almost any
president in my lifetime and senator
he's uh I know he has a he's had some
choice words for you mostly because of
the mahler deal and Rosenstein he wasn't
thrilled with that pick either but do
you think you'll ultimately get his
endorsement I hope so
certainly I'm going to work for that and
will be seeking it he doesn't always get
involved in primaries so I understand
that and he's indicated he probably
would not in this one but yes I would
love to have his support because I ask
people first I ask the people of Alabama
and throughout the country to trust him
to support him and I thought he was the
one who could win and if he won I
thought he would bring that drive that
energy that will extraordinary to
advance his agenda yeah you're
absolutely right and I was in Alabama
over the weekend and overwhelming
support for you in the state of Alabama
and your run senator sessions thank you
for being with us tonight we really
appreciate it Thank You Laura and